an auto race of a different kind this
one's putting major players like GM Ford
and Tesla and a battle to sell you your
first or next electric vehicle Chris Van
Cleave has a look at who's pulling ahead
and who may be falling behind
I go home I plug it in that's it Chris
actually is so happy with his electric
Ford F-150 he's looking for an EV to
replace his other car why do you want to
go with two electrics I think I was
really just tired of buying gas to be
honest with you but he's not seriously
considering the market leader Tesla
seeing all the other options come on the
market as well definitely made a
difference and you know makes it easier
to not feel like you're pigeonholed into
a certain decision and Ashley is not
alone while Tesla makes up an enormous
65 percent of the U.S EV market now
their share has dropped steadily down
six percent from last year and off 14
from 2020. Tesla has two problems in
them they need to get their cars more
affordable and they need to get more
fresh cars to Market as well and they
don't really seem to have any product in
the pipeline that can fix that Tim
Stevens is a world car award judge who
tracks the Auto industry they still
stand to grow as a business overall but
in terms of being the global market
leader it's hard to imagine being being
in that position in 2025 at least the
way their current portfolio is going
electric vehicles share of the auto
market has doubled since 2021. experts
estimate within three years there will
be 159 different EV models with Ford and
General Motors forecast to pass Tesla in
market share by 2025. Tesla did not
respond to requests for comment so the
battery go just like Aaron Palmer is
Ford's VP of electrics every person who
takes one home
tells all their friends and family and
then they experience it and then they
start thinking about buying a vehicle GM
is betting on its electric Silverado
Blazer and Equinox we got a first look
at it ahead of its launch next year
starting around thirty thousand dollars
this is the vehicle you think that
drives Eevee adoption this is everything
because this is the heart of the volume
in the market and when you can come in
around that thirty thousand dollar price
point we think we got a great
opportunity to take market share and get
car Shoppers like Chris Ashley out of a
gas guzzler and plugged in to an
electric future for CBS Saturday morning
I'm Chris Van Cleave in Frederick
Maryland
[Music]
you know one of the things I've noticed
when you see new parking garages going
up lots buildings a lot more places to
charge or first time ever places to
charge and that's where you see the
difference happening and they still need
a lot more yeah there's no doubt about
it